One of the things I do on this program is I tell
you honestly and directly when a political issue
is merely a political football and has a public
facing debate that is essentially meaningless.
Now, one such issue that is a political football
is debt and deficit. We've talked about it
endlessly. Republicans claim to care about debt
and deficit until a Republican is president. And
then when George W. Bush blows up the deficit,
when Donald Trump blows up the deficit,
they say nothing. And then now they're back on it
because Joe Biden is president. It's a meaningless
political football. It doesn't get into the meat
of when is national debt good, bad, problematic
interest on the debt. Japan, China, holders of
know all these different thing doesn't get to it.
It's just a meaningless political football. It's
a deflated football. We could call it another.
Such political football whose public debate is
meaningless is gas prices. Now, if you've been
listening to our podcast for a while, if you've
been watching this show for some time, you know,
I never played into this. My position, whether
the president is a Republican or a Democrat is
presidents have some, but relatively little to
do with gas prices over the long term. And you
can fact check me on this, go back and check
out my clips during past presidents and you
will find that I've been consistent. I don't play
the gas price games, whether it's during Trump in
twenty eighteen in a clip called Gas Prices Hit
three year high where I say this has little to
do with Trump, it's mostly seasonal. Or you go
back to 2015 under Barack Obama in a clip called
Dollar Ninety Nine Gas Returns where I say this
really doesn't have to do much with Barack Obama.
There are probably about a dozen or so clips
that we've done about this issue. In general, gas
prices go up in the summer when demand is higher,
they go down in the winter when demand is lower.
In general, global supply issues, rather than an
American president impact gas prices. And right
now, gas prices are up about 18 to 20 percent over
the last few months. And very quickly, once again,
you are starting to see the hot takes blaming
Joe Biden. And the story that they are telling
is Trump kept gas prices low. Joe Biden came in
and gas prices have skyrocketed. Now, neither
is true in a causal way. And we're going to look
at it. But some examples. The official Republican
Twitter account tweeting, quote, President Biden's
energy agenda will raise gas prices even higher by
shutting down American energy production. That's
not true. Here's Republican House minority leader.
And it gives me great pleasure to remind you
he's the minority leader, Kevin McCarthy,
including gas prices in his sort of grievance
list against Joe Biden just a few days ago.
Look what has happened in the short
amount of time they've controlled all
your gasoline prices up. Biden has created
a crisis on the border that he won't admit.
There was also a widely shared Facebook post
whose basic message was when sleepy Joe came in,
diesel was a dollar sixty nine. Today, Diesel is
319, thanks to all that voted for this clown. Now,
the numbers are wrong in that post, but the
causality is also gone. So I could go on and
on with more examples. But here's the truth. This
has nothing to do with Joe Biden. And it started
before Joe Biden was president. First of all,
gas prices move on a delay in response to oil
supply issues. It's a much slower process than
some Republicans want you to think right now.
And in this case, we know why gas prices are up.
It's the inverse reason of why they were down in
twenty twenty, the price of oil and thus gasoline
collapsed in 2020 due to no demand. It costs money
to store oil. And when demand for gas is down, you
don't necessarily want to keep refining oil at the
same clip because there's not demand for it. So
you store the oil and demand was down so much
due to the pandemic. People not flying, people not
commuting cruise industry shutdown that the price
of oil and gas collapsed. Now, as vaccination is
rolling out, as cases are declining, as air travel
is returning, as commuting is returning, demand
is increasing and it's actually in some areas
increasing very quickly. So gas prices are going
up globally. It's not just in the United States.
This has nothing to do with Joe Biden. But then
here's. The cherry on top, many Republican talking
points require not understanding how time time
works or believing in time travel. If you look
at a chart of gas or diesel prices, here's a chart
of diesel prices up on the screen. You will notice
the increase started in October under Donald Trump
and it simply continued during Trump's presidency
in November. In December, the first two thirds
of January, then Joe Biden took over and the gas
and diesel price increase is continuing
and it is related to demand coming back
as the pandemic hopefully starts to wane.
Don't fall for this stuff. It'll rot your brain
as as I like to say. And it's not borne out
by the facts. It's not borne out by the data.
It is not Joe Biden's fault that gas prices are
up and importantly, gas prices being up is a good
sign that demand is returning. And hopefully
if we keep vaccinating, if we start getting
vaccines to more countries more quickly
and we continue vaccinating more quickly,
we will we will see significant
economic improvements that, yes,
might go with, you know, a tank of gas costing a
few dollars more for the average consumer vehicle.